let's get more now on uh breaking news
we brought you within the last few
minutes and a woman killed in a dog
attack in Surrey earlier this month has
been named today we can get more details
from Ivor Bennett who's following the
story for us from The Newsroom either
yes the victim of that very tragic and
distressing incident has been named as
Natasha Johnston a 28 year old woman
from London who's believed to have been
a professional dog walker she died when
she was attacked by dogs on January the
12th in the Gravelly Hill area of
Caterham in Surrey it's a very popular
and well-known Beauty Spot popular with
dog walkers and Ms Johnson is believed
to have been walking several dogs when
she was attacked and eyewitnesses have
previously told Sky News how they saw a
woman on the floor being attacked by
multiple dogs and how she screamed at
other passes by to turn back paramedics
did arrive but they were unable to save
her police seized eight dogs at the
scene and they remain in police custody
as forensic investigations
on the dogs continue but sorry police
have already said that none of the dogs
that were seized are banned breeds under
the dangerous dogs act and they said
last week that nobody will be prosecuted
for this attack having already concluded
their criminal investigation but what
will happen now is that a Coroner's
inquest into Miss Johnson's death will
open
um it'll be done by Surrey coron and
that's expected to open tomorrow the aim
obviously is to establish exactly how
this young woman lost her life in such a
tragic way either thank you Ivor Bennett
with the latest on that breaking news